who knows a thing or two about America's
role in the world it's congressman Mike
Turner a Republican from Ohio who is
also the chairman of the US delegation
to the NATO Parliamentary Assembly I had
the honor of serving with mr. Turner in
the Congress and I think you serve for
being here when I thought about what was
going on with NATO me look I was
convinced when I was a member of
Congress you probably knew more than
just about anybody at least in the House
of Representatives as it relates to NATO
earlier I put up a graphic about the
tens of billions of dollars that are now
starting to flow to our NATO partners
what sort of effect do you think Trump
has had although unconventional in
pushing our NATO partners to pony up and
pay their fair share absolutely he's had
a huge impact and and this is an
important impact because this goes right
to not only just our national security
but the national security of the overall
alliance you know in 2014 at the Wales
summit the NATO allies made a commitment
to reach 2% this is something that they
agreed to it's not being imposed upon
them by the United States but at the
same time they were not reaching this
goal president after president secretary
defence after secretary defence would
point this out and would chastise our
NATO allies but no real movement was
being made now the president has come in
is holding them accountable requiring it
they've come forward with plans to reach
the goal and as you just described you
know an untold amount of money is now
flowing into their own militaries which
then are contributed overall to NATO's
capability he's having a huge and very
positive impact on the capability and
the funding for NATO military goals and
objectives you know what's fascinating
to me about this we're gonna show you a
quick bit of footage this is Donald
Trump on Oprah Winfrey program 30 years
ago listen to what Donald Trump said 30
years ago what would you do differently
Don I'd make our allies forgetting about
the enemies the enemies you can't talk
to so easily I'd make our allies pay
their fair share
pretty interesting that he said that I
thought it was actually interesting
watching that for about the fifth time
you know talking to our enemies it's not
so easy and I think we kind of
demonstrated that but for him to say
pushing our allies to phony up and pay
their fair share I mean that's something
that the
that Donald Trump is done how is that
work in terms of conventional forces but
then also the space race you've heard
the president announce a new a new push
there Estonia a NATO ally is critical in
their cyber front what's the balance
there and how is that money how would
you like to see that money spent well I
think first off I think the president in
articulating even 30 years ago and today
that the bill for defending NATO should
not be sent to the United States that
the NATO ally should share that burden
is absolutely where the American people
people are and I think that needs to be
communicated clear to the allies well
you know Russia itself has an economy
somewhere between that of Italy or Spain
not Italy and Spain yet they have a
military that's capable of threatening
all of Europe what we need to see from
our European counterparts are
investments in real capabilities we have
for deployed our forces to help counter
some of the aggressiveness of Russia
along the border but they need to look
at real capabilities ground capabilities
air capabilities so that they can
actually deter Russia this is a real
issue of not just you know can you win
in a conflict or you know how do we
engage in in deployments but how do we
avoid conflict and that avoidance of
conflict is investing in deterrence and
that's having a military capable of of
your adversary looking and saying you
know I don't want to mess with you this
cost would be too high but there are a
lot of people that are concerned that
now that there's six hundred plus
billion dollars nearly seven hundred
billion dollars going into the military
where other countries China Russia and
others can play at an equal footing with
the United States is in the cyber front
so how do we attack that where do we
spend that money and what do we do when
we know that Russia is attacking the
United States on the cyber front right
absolutely anew you are absolutely
correct that we do know this well we're
doing it on a couple of levels one
obviously is trying to work with both
industry and with the government
infrastructure to try to fortify our you
know our electronic system so that we're
they're not subject to hacking working
also with our allies so that they're not
a backdoor to all of this but then also
we need to hone our skills as the
president has said in doing to our
adversaries
our adversaries do to us and making
certain that we have an ability to have
a presence that also can counter and
hold them at bay from hurting us yeah I
think this is one of the big questions
for our country and for our population
if somebody were a lot missiles at us
you can fire back but when somebody
attacks us electronically how do you
fire back
congressman Turner I thank you for
joining us tonight a real expert in this
innocent I thank you for being here